you must have heard about certain brands
of supercars that are said to move very
fast think about sports cars a Ferrari
or even better a Lamborghini all the
examples of supercards with super speed
and a high level of performance now
imagine this Supercar being recreated in
the form of a submarine that would be
pretty cool right well in today's video
we take a look at the first Supercar
submarine in the world entering the
Uncharted Territory of deep ocean
exploration the U-Boat Works Nemo 2 is
the first Supercar submarine to ever be
created in the world there it is this
Supercar submarine is the first of its
kind and was built by a Dutch company
u-boatworks which is known for creating
the only existing private submarines in
the world the Nemo was created by a
committed group of Submarine pilots who
focused on developing an owner-centric
design during its creation owners and
Pilots hailed the initial model produced
in 2021 for its superb handling
abilities and exciting diving experience
having created the Nemo one that can
only occupy one person spectacular
company goes on to create another which
is the Nemo 2 and can occupy a total of
two people the Nemo 2 costs a whopping
590
000 only forty five thousand dollars
more than the price of the Nemo one at
545 000 the price of the Nemo 2 had just
recently been brought down from one
million dollars due to the mass
production the Supercar submarine is
undergoing for easy access to it by
private bodies nothing is more
liberating than diving into an unknown
world of exploration and Discovery in
the safety of your own Nemo Submarine we
are excited to see volume production of
the Nemo usher in a new era of ocean
exploration said Nemo product manager
Lex van riesewick in a conversation
about the mass production of the Nemo
Supercar submarine of course one would
not expect such an astonishing vehicle
to go for an amount less than that
because this submarine can only be one
of the top exotic toys for millionaires
with a weight totaling
5510 pounds and only 280 centimeters by
a hundred in length the Nemo two
Supercar submarine is so small that it
can fit in the dock of a super yacht
basically it's roughly the size of two
water skis due to its breadth of 92
inches or 231 centimeters it can
comfortably fit a passenger and a pilot
with each having a separate seat there
is a small hatch on top of the submarine
which you have to open to enter the
submarine and right at the center of the
submarine a big orb is firmly located
there this section is where you get to
sit down alongside your pilot or if you
are the pilot then alongside your
passenger to enjoy the beautiful
underwater view one of the most
astounding features of this Supercar
submarine is its diminutive size which
enables you to easily attach it behind
your SUV and leave it on land at your
boat dock or even better on your yacht
you might be on a relaxed sea trip with
your friends and things start to get
well boring but with your Supercar
submarine right on your yacht you can
all take turns diving deeper into the
water using the submarine and take the
fun up a notch you might be wondering
what if my submarine crashes into a rock
well you would be glad to know that this
super car submarine right here is
protected by a five centimeter Ultra
thick windshield made of acrylic so
trust me you are safe in this even
though the windshield is extremely thick
it still gives passengers a clear and
deep viewing area of the ocean's depths
as once you get in the view is as clear
as being outside of it being submerged
under water in the submarine is even
more impressive the U-Boat Works
submarine Pilots have boasted some
remarkable performance figures for the
Supercar submarine which is packed with
a range of insanely Advanced high-tech
thanks to the vehicle's full 330 foot
depth capability you can see aquatic
creatures that you wouldn't be able to
see with a typical scuba dive an
interesting addition is the incredible
Craft's ability to go at a top speed of
up to three knots underwater and since
the Nemo may work for up to eight hours
straight you wouldn't need to hurry back
to the surface the only thing you have
to do is enjoy your view for a little
longer and tell me in the comments
section how your experience was whilst
underwater you may see a few water
Treasures that are worth Gathering
there's a little five-point arm on the
side of this submarine that you can use
to grab onto things that you may find
interesting these could be pretty exotic
things such as gold coins some gemstones
or maybe even an alien saucer whichever
one grabs your attention just take
control of the robotic arm to reach out
grab the treasure and take it back home
it is important to note though that this
arm is an optional add-on as the
submarine does not come with the arm you
can however pay a little bit more and
request that it be added onto your
submarine but I think it will be cool to
have this arm and whilst you're diving
100 meters underwater you can collect
really interesting things and voila you
have your treasure to yourself the water
depth of 330 feet cannot be reached
without sufficient training though if
you were to purchase a Nemo 2 the first
step that you would need to take is a
certified training session that U-Boat
Works offers to all customers in person
you will learn how to drive a
submersible vehicle during this two-week
full-time course the owner will graduate
from the program with a certification in
submarine operation Additionally you
have the choice of asking for a pilot
for your ex exclusive enjoyment and
access to more entertainment the
translucent glass cockpit of this
submarine has in-cabin speakers
alongside this is another optional extra
known as the sonar placed right below in
the middle of the outer part of this
Supercar submarine the sonar is a blue
object that serves as an extra pair of
eyes for you how so let us take this
scenario for example say you are
submerged underwater in your submarine
and then at some point the visibility
right there goes blurry and unclear
making it difficult to move further or
even enjoy the view this will send out
the sonar and you will be able to get
some sort of a map on your dashboard
screen to direct you without even
bothering to see with your eyes what I
find super cool about this Supercar
submarine is that just like that you can
add a robotic arm and a sonar and you
can also change or add a few other
things you want on it you can decide to
change the color the entire interior and
so many other physical changes you may
want to make on your submarine whichever
way you want the entire C is your limit
just be sure your finances can handle
the strain because these upgrades are
not cheap I'm pretty sure I already have
you on board right here and you must
already be thinking of getting one of
these amazing sea crafts however I'm not
done telling you about the Supercar as
there is still more to know let's carry
on knowing that 100 meters underwater is
deep and that it can get very dark down
there U-Boat Works Pilots were smart
enough to add bright lights to the outer
part of this Supercar submarine this
will Aid your visibility and help guide
you as they are super powerful enough to
cut through the vast Darkness let's not
forget that this vehicle must be powered
by a certain type of power for it to
maintain its strong and super fast
Mobility fully added to power up this
amazing craft are battery-powered
electric propulsions which are placed
right behind the submarine also placed
behind a submarine is a grip tape I mean
a grip area where you can put your feet
on whilst trying to get into the
submarine the only way you probably
wouldn't need this is if you could fly
into the submarine just kidding but with
the door to the sub being at the back
this grip enables you to climb into the
submarine easily and safely too still at
the back of the submarine is an exposed
dashboard that you can open up and an
oxygen tank comes into view now this
part isn't necessary for the Supercar to
run however if anything goes wrong then
be sure that you will be needing this
tank hopefully nothing does happen but
once it does you or your passenger could
go to this section of the submarine and
fill the tank with oxygen which then
makes the entire submarine float up say
for example you see something that blows
your mind away and you eventually pass
out for safety purposes a panic button
fills a little oxygen tank at the back
of your submarine with oxygen and then
floats to the ocean surface by itself
alongside this is your robot hand holder
and a fire extinguisher for when
something terrible such as an
uncontrollable fire outbreak happens man
a fire outbreak underwater just open up
the latch and swim away once that
happens guys a Marlin controller for
remotely navigating the Nemo is also
housed inside this submarine in case you
want to explore from a safe spot all of
the navigational information is
displayed and there are numerous buttons
with different functions such as the CO2
scrubber bilge pump air monitor backup a
squelch and a variety of other buttons
you might think that the controls of
this submarine will seem intimidating
but the Manta controller makes them easy
to understand the Manta controller looks
like a combination of a joystick and a
PlayStation filled with a few buttons
it's straightforward and enables precise
targeted movements just like playing a
video game all of this is pretty
self-explanatory I mean one can imagine
driving a military submarine in
comparison to this relatively
straightforward Supercar submarine the
Nemo 2 also comes with air conditioning
a wireless communication system and a
navigation system to help increase the
percentage of you getting a fantastic
ride on this submarine so far no one has
been said to purchase this Supercar
submarine or they probably do not want
that to be known but I can only think of
Elon Musk attempting to purchase it soon
given the fact that he has an obsession
with supercars it's said that he once
paid 1 million dollars to own James
Bond's Lotus Esprit submarine car from
the well-known movie the spy who loved
me either way this Supercar submarine is
an amazing craft and if you have Deep
Pockets I think you should get one of
these what do you think of this Supercar
submarine if you like this video make
sure to click a card on your screen for
more content like this